I am on a train with no brakes going
backwards and not just any train this is
Stephenson's rocket which was built in
when was it Chris 1829 1829 well it's
not the original that's on the Science
Museum this is a replica from 150 years
later that is in the National Railway
Museum in York but for all intents and
purposes this is Stephenson's rocket and
it has no brakes Chris tell them why
tell them something they might not know
okay when this is built proper brakes
really haven't been invented you had a
handbrake for when you were stood still
and we also on this loco have modern
brakes because that's the law but we try
not to use them we try to be authentic
so the way will break is literally well
we're going backwards of the motor so
we'll stick it in forwards gear that
will put steam into the cylinders on the
opposite side and bring us gradually to
a nice slow halt then we'll just saunter
off in the opposite direction no it
seems like that would damage it it seems
like because I'm a regular gearbox when
you hit that and put it there we go into
reverse it feels like that should mesh
the gears wrongly that's not what's
happening here it's just injecting steam
the other way
that's exactly right their cylinder
moves backwards and forwards like this
we just put the steam into the direction
that the cylinder wants to move it tries
to compress the theme and that
resistance slows the loco down and so we
come steadily to a stop like here and
then once we hit though it just starts
going the other way that is wonderful
that is how he stopped Stephenson's
rocket that is a train with no brakes
and that thank you to Chris Charlie and
the National Railway Museum is something
you might not have known